bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct dans notre édition de 22h le
suspens autour de la crise grecque
continue sortira sortira pas de la zone
euro y dition spécial encore ce soir à
22 heures après l'intervention
aujourd'huide alexis tsipras sow
parlement de strasbourg
le premier ministre grec a été applaudi
par la gauche huée par la droite
dans un hémicycle européen en ébullition
vous l'entendrez le discours aussi cet
après-midi de manuel valls était à
l'assemblée nationale le premier
ministre a annoncé qu'il y aurait un
vote du parlement français sur un accord
éventuel avec la grèce et puis ce soir
christine lagarde l'a sur une
restructuration de la dette grecque est
nécessaire c'est ce que vient de
déclarer la directrice générale du fonds
monétaire international nous y
reviendrons dans cette édition avec le
club des éditorialistes
bruno jeudy et laurent joffrin seront
avec nous ce soir le débat politique
également avec bruno retailleau nicolas
dupont aignan et christophe caresche qui
seront avec nous sur ce plateau fou
après le sommet extraordinaire de
l'union européenne hier qui n'a donc
débouché sur aucun accord
alexis tsipras c'était ce matin devant
le parlement européen le premier
ministre grec est venu réclamer un
meilleur partage du fardeau
face à un hémicycle enflammé sandra
cerqueira en arrivant au parlement
européen
alexis tsipras ce savait que ses amis
l'attendaient
côté français jean luc mélenchon et le
parti de gauche côté espagnol podemos un
hémicycle en ébullition partagé entre
les applaudissements et les huées le
premier ministre grec est venue rappeler
son attachement à la zone euro et promet
des réformes dans deux jours mais pas
sous la pression de l'austérité une
austérité déjà imposées par l'europe
responsable selon lui de la situation
dans son pays et il ne mâche pas ses
mots pour le dire
on peut dire que mon pays ces cinq
dernières années est devenu
un champ d'expérimentation de
l'austérité mais nous devons bien voir
la réalité en face l'expérience a échoué
ces cinq dernières années le chômage a
explosé la pauvreté pas explosé la
marginalisation l'exclusion sociale se
sont développées ferme mais rassurant
aussi le premier ministre grec a tenu à
minimiser le non au référendum et gestes
d'ouverture continue de prôner un accord
tout en se disant favorable à la
recherche d'une solution sur la dette
aux micros plusieurs députés prennent à
partie le premier ministre grec
la droite dénonce un discours politicien
sans fond koulou parler de réformes mais
se réforment où nous ne voyons nous n'en
voyons pas la couleur sous forme de
propositions concrètes
il faut que vous ayez une feuille de
route que vous ayez un calendrier les
intentions qu'on ne suffisent pas
montrer que vous êtes un vrai dirigeant
et par un faux prophète
marine le pen appelle l la grèce à
sortir de l'euro après tant d'erreurs il
est largement temps de dissoudre de
manière concertée la zone euro de
conserver l'euro comme monnaie commune
les économies des pays d'europe se
porter au mieux et les tensions entre
les peuples s'apaiseront enfin alexis
tsipras continue de jouer avec les nerfs
des européens
le temps passe et de plus en plus de
dirigeants assurent que si nul ne veut
le grec cite personne ne peut l'exclure
pour autant si la confiance n'est pas au
rendez vous et puis on vient de
l'apprendre à l'instant les banques
grecques resteront fermés jusqu'à lundi
prochain selon une source du ministère
des finances
la grèce s'est donc engagé aujourd'hui à
des réformes crédibles en échange d'un
prêt sur trois ans que va-t-il donc se
passer dans les trois prochains jours et
dans les prochains jours le compte à
rebours a commencé avant le sommet
européen de la dernière chance ce sera
dimanche prochain
les 28 dirigeants européens se
retrouveront à bruxelles pour statuer
sur le sort d'athènes jérôme rabier
après le référendum de dimanche dernier
les ultimatums des créanciers place à la
semaine de tous les dangers
car les dirigeants européens ont prévenu
il n'y aura plus de délai accordé à la
grèce
le compte à rebours est donc lancé sans
unité sur la grèce nous allons nous
réveiller dans quatre jours dans une
europe différente
c'est vraiment l'heure décisive et
finale pour la grèce comme pour nous
c'est notre dernière chance
d'ici dimanche plusieurs rendez-vous
sont attendus et c'est dès demain que la
grèce doit remettre ses propositions de
réformes en échange d'un prêt sur trois
ans via le mécanisme européen de
stabilité
une demande d'argent frais déposer dès
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement d'alexis
tsipras ce en échange la grèce pourrait
s'engager à réformer dès la semaine
prochaine son système de retraites et sa
fiscalité
pour donner des gages de bonne volonté
leur groupe se réunira ensuite samedi
pour évaluer la crédibilité des
propositions grecques avant un sommet
européen dimanche qui réunira les 28
dirigeants de l'union européenne y
compris ceux n'appartenant pas à la zone
euro
deux scénarios sont ensuite envisager
swahili accord et l'aide financière à la
grèce est débloquée assurant un avenir
au pays dans la zone euro soit les états
n'arrivent pas à s'entendre et c'est
alors le scénario du grec cite une
sortie du pays de la zone euro et ses
conséquences incertaines qui est
enclenchée les quatre prochains jours
s'annonce donc chargée et décisif pour
l'avenir de l'unité européenne et de sa
monnaie
le parlement français a également
débattu cet après-midi de la situation
grecque
manuel valls a fait un vibrant plaidoyer
en faveur de la grèce une passion
française selon le premier ministre qui
a affirmé que les propositions formulées
aujourd'hui par athènes sont équilibrés
et positive on écoute manuel valls le
maintien de la grèce dans l'euro est
donc au coeur de l'europe dans l'union
européenne
c'est aussi et vous le savez un enjeu
géostratégique et géopolitique de la
plus haute importance
le temps est à l'action mais je vais
être très clair devant vous comme l'a
dit hier soir le président de la
république après le conseil
quelle que soit l'issue l'assemblée
nationale aura à se prononcer et s'il ya
accord
l'assemblée devra se prononcer par un
vote
voilà puis ce débat sur la crise grecque
également une
aujourd'hui au sénat regardez ce compte
rendu de séance avec molière souci
laurent fabius vient délivrer le message
de manuel valls aux sénateurs c'est le
ministre des affaires étrangères qui a
lu le discours que le premier ministre
tenait au même moment à l'assemblée
nationale c'est la démocratie c'est un
choix très important et donc il est
normal que les parlementaires sur la
socié une présence en partie dû au
président du groupe socialiste il avait
écrit au premier ministre pour que le
débat se tienne aussi au sénat et
j'avais souhaité que le gouvernement
fasse le même débat au sénat qu à
l'assemblée nationale il a lieu cet
après-midi j'entends beaucoup de
transparence et beaucoup de clarté et
j'y vais vite parce que ça commençait
l'inquiétude autour de la situation
grecque n'apaise pas les tensions deux
parties la droite attaque françois
hollande et sa position de consensus
jugé pas assez tranchantes
force est de reconnaître que le
leadership de la france s'est exercé
avec l'ancien président de la république
et qu'aujourd'hui on constate l'absence
de leadership de la france sur toutes
les grandes questions européennes
toutes les sensibilités étaient
représentés l'occasion pour
l'extrême-gauche d'envoyer un nouveau
message de soutien au premier ministre
grec l'europe d'alexis tsipras c'est
celle du progrès social et écologique de
la solidarité de la démocratie de la
coopération consenti cette europe c'est
la nôtre ce débat était simplement
consultatif mais gérard larcher a déjà
demandé qu'en cas de nouveau plan daide
ou de sortie de la grèce de la zone euro
les parlementaires puissent exprimer par
un vote et bien enfin nicolas sarkozy
était ce soir l'invité du 20 heures de
tf1 pour le président des républicains
tout doit être fait pour trouver un
compromis sur la grèce sans détruire la
crédibilité de la zone euro on écoute
nicolas sarkozy sion être fait pour
trouver un compromis
je partage ce point de vue exprimé par
monsieur hollande et par monsieur valls
mais il ya une ligne rouge c'est que le
compromis qui doit être trouvée ne doit
pas détruire la crédibilité des 18
autres pays membres de la zone euro
premier débat ce soir de cette édition
spéciale de 22 heures consacrées encore
et toujours à ce feuilleton grec avec le
débat politique et nos invités qui nous
ont rejoints sur ce plateau bruno
retailleau bonsoir nous savons que le
président de groupe l'est républicain
ici au sénat christophe caresche bon
soir député socialiste de paris et puis
nicolas dupont aignan député également
président de debout la france a et puis
hervé baudry notre dessinateur qui nous
accompagne tout surpris mercredi bonsoir
est revenu au niveau de gris celui ci
dessous ni ma voix que sinon je
dessinerai puis vous verrez à ma place à
mon avis on va pouvoir compléter donc
sur la crise grecque on attend les
propositions de réforme de la grèce
demain et puis un éventuel accord est ce
que vous y croyez encore bruno
retailleau bas a coûté faut toujours y
croire jusqu'au bout
moi ce que j'ai indiqué à la tribune du
sénat c'est qu'il ya deux écueils il
faut se préserver le premier écueil ce
serait un petit arrangement un petit
bricolage c'est à dire qu'on prête 15 20
milliards d'euros de plus à la grèce
sans que celle-ci ne s'engage sans que
celles ci respecte ses engagements cela
alourdira la dette
et puis dans six mois dans un an on se
retrouve au même niveau ça fait depuis
cinq ans trois fois que la grèce est en
risque de défaut et puis ce qui serait
aussi terrible c'est un grec cite plutôt
ingres excitante c'est à dire une sortie
brutale non contrôlée de la zone euro de
la grèce voilà après il me semble
d'abord il vaudrait mieux un accord qui
soit un vrai accord avec le respect des
engagements si cet accord est pas
possible parce qu'il ferait que cet
accord fassent l'objet de clause de
revoyure régulière il faudra une sortie
incontrôlée de la grèce avec des
aménagements sans doute un drame lié à
l'euro et c'est christophe caresche
depuis des semaines maintenant les
français suivent ce feuilleton grec
parfois avec lassitude surtout avec
inquiétude
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de leur
dire ce soir que je pense qu'il est
possible d'en sortir et d'en sortir
positivement bas ont négocié
en discutant c'est ce que fait le
président de la république ils essayent
de rapprocher les points de vue il se
bat pour essayer de faire en sorte que
la négociation se noue elle a failli
aboutir avant le référendum on n'était
pas loin de l'accord et d'un bon accord
ça va comprennent toujours la position
de françois hollande
elle est pourtant des grecs et puis par
les uns ou les autres il s'est pas mis
dans cette situation-là
d'ailleurs depuis depuis qu'il est
président la république françois
hollande n'a jamais voulu être le porte
parole par exemple des pays du sud ça
n'a jamais été son son objectif son
objectif c'est de jouer un rôle positif
d'essayer de d'accoucher du compromis
est dans le moment où on est de
préserver la zone euro parce que ce qui
est vrai c'est qu'une sortie de la grèce
pour l'instant personne ne s'est
véritablement ce que cela produit cola
dupont aignan j'imagine que vous avez
suivi l'intervention assez fort les
interventions des uns et des autres
est-ce que tu prasad l impression de
vouloir sortir la zone euro ce matin
écoutez vous savez il ya deux dangers il
ya le danger des allemands qui veulent
punir la grèce qui ont imposé des plans
d'austérité qui n'ont pas marché c'est
mon sentiment et ça n'a pas marché
puisque l'austérité a détruit ce pays
est en vérité on se retrouve avec une
dette encore plus importante et le pire
c'est qu'on a engagé des contribuables
avant c'était la dette des banques
c'est d'ailleurs nicolas sarkozy je
remarque qui a transféré avec la
complicité des socialistes la dette des
banques sur le contribuable français
j'avais à l'époque tellement j'avais à
l'époque tu ne dis danger à l'assemblée
nationale vous pouvez trouver mes
interventions
ça c'est le premier danger et puis à
l'autre danger c'est d'avoir un accord
où on donne encore de l'argent à la
grèce parce que vous allez rajouter 20 à
50 milliards et la grèce ne s'en sortira
pas davantage pour une raison simple que
le mal c'est l'euro qui est une monnaie
trop cher pour la grèce dont moi je
revendique une salle sur certains oui je
vous dis que la seule solution
raisonnable
c'est une sortie organisée accompagner
un étalement de la dette dans le temps
pour donner une bouffée d'oxygène
une monnaie commune euros drague plutôt
que l'euro qui permettra à la grèce de
dévaluer sa monnaie et donc de restaurer
sa productivité et sa compétitivité
il n'y a pas d'autre issue alors on
amuse la galerie encore cette semaine
mais je vous verrez que lundi on sortira
la grèce simplement j'aimerais qu'elles
sortent en douceur et pas brutalement
certaines grecque qui viennent casser en
tout cas il ya un câble qui viennent
casser on ne sait pas si le deuxième va
casser ça va du violon pas où on garde
un petit peu de suspense pour la fin de
semaine ont amusé la galerie
j'ai un point de désaccord et un point
d'accord avec nicolas dupont aignan le
point des records c'est que je pense que
les grecs sont aussi responsables de ce
qui se passe c'est clair ils n'ont
jamais voulu tenir leurs engagements
il y à un état qui est un état
clientéliste il y a en même temps une
économique et une économie de rente et
monsieur de chypre a en réalité a revêtu
les habits de robin des bois au service
des armateurs donc il ya une énorme je
dire gap fossé
non mais écoutez non mais il gouverne
avec beaucoup de démagogie
bref le point d'accord je pense qu'il
faut s'interroger si un bon accord avec
de vraies prises responsabilité des
grecs n'est pas possible
il vaut mieux envisager une sorte de
mise en congé parce que je pense que si
demain la grèce avait avec cet accord
négocié une monnaie qu'elle dévaluerait
je pense qu'il vaut toujours mieux faire
un ajustement monétaire plutôt que des
ajustements réel sur l'activité la
croissance
les salaires et finalement le chômage
donc je suis favorable d'abord un bon
accord mais 6e passé bon d'accord vous
croyez vraiment qu'après le succès du
référendum de dimanche
la greffe à l'exception trace est prêt à
accepter des réformes qu'il a refusé
jusqu'à jusqu'à ces derniers jours
d'agonie
c'est une nécessité pas par un pape
uniquement par rapport à la négociation
mais c'est une nécessité par rapport à
son pays la question de la grèce
il ya eu des erreurs de commises vous
avez raison de le dire mais la question
de la grèce c'est quand même une
situation intérieure d'abord avec aussi
là aussi beaucoup d'éléments on les
connaît politiques qui ont amené cette
situation si la grèce ne fait pas un
certain nombre de réformes qu'elle soit
ou non dans la zone euro elle aura les
mêmes problèmes
donc pour la grèce le fait de rester
dans la zone aux roues c'est une chance
c'est une chance parce que elle aura la
garantie d'être accompagné dans dans les
réformes et dans la capacité de
retrouver une dynamique économique
la vraie question est de savoir si la
grèce veut c'est faire ces réformes
l'avenir si elle est lâché seul si elles
sortent de la zone euro elle sera elle
sera de toute façon obligés de les faire
parce que si elle est seule elle sera
confrontée en quelques heures l'esclave
carresse quel que soit le cas de figure
sortie à la zone euro qui attend la
grèce c'est pas de l'austérité c'est
mais c'est aussi de l'investissement
dans le plan qui avait été proposé par
monsieur juncker
il ya 30 milliards d'investissements que
que l'europe est prêt à mettre sur la
table il n'y a pas d'exemple dans
l'histoire économique du monde dans
l'histoire économique du monde n'y a pas
d'exemple de plans d'austérité qui
réussit s'il n'ya pas en même temps une
dévaluation monétaire il ya eu deux
exemples qui ont été des fiascos affreux
l'entre-deux-guerres ou l'allemagne
avant hitler a refusé de dévaluer il ya
une récession terrible on a imposé une
cure d'austérité saané hitler au pouvoir
et le deuxième exemple c'est laval dans
les années 30
car refuser dévaluer le franc vous
pouvez avoir de l'austérité si
parallèlement vous d'évaluer votre
monnaie pour redonner de l'oxygène aux
entreprises et réapprendre à la grèce a
pêché au lieu de lui donner
éternellement du poisson c'est la créer
il faut regarder les faits historiques
regardez les pays qui ont réussi un
exemple la suède en 92 dévaluer sa
monnaie et fait une cure d'austérité
et elle n'est pas dans l'euro est ce que
vous savez
membrez la souffrance en grèce a été
deux fois pire qu'au portugal et en
espagne 25 % de baisse du pib' 30 % des
entreprises ont disparu eux qu'ils ne
soient pas que la grèce soit la france
on est tous d'accord mais vous ne
changerez pas le peuple grec par décret
il faut ça donne en mille c'est facile à
lire des réformes à faire comme ça
est-ce que vous avez été en grèce pour
la souffrance des gens c'est facile de
dire du haut d'une tribune vous rendez
compte de ce qui s'est passé en or vous
ne pouvez pas imposer des réformes s'il
n'y a pas de croissance économique par
un relais de développement
on a la preuve depuis cinq ans on va pas
continuer ce qui a échoué depuis cinq
ans c'est louis xiii honnêtement c'est
le problème
il ya un problème qui est quand même un
problème grec et un problème de prise de
responsabilité avec un problème de
fiabilité de monsieur type race on ne
peut avoir d'accord ferme
sûr qu'avec des interlocuteurs fiables
pas d interlocuteur qui quitte la
tonalité jeu on a des doutes
en tout cas il y a des doutes simplement
vous soulever une question
moi je trouve que la france a été
complètement effacés et que françois
hollande qui a eu finalement beaucoup de
complaisance la complaisance si la
complaisance d'une forme de romantisme
de gauche vis-à-vis d'une gauche
radicale grève depuis le départ ce qui
fait que la france est en panne
exactement eh bien la france est absente
la france a laissé finalement la grèce
s'enfermer dans un face à face avec
l'allemagne ça n'était pas rendre
service ni à l'europe je crois ni aux
grecs
et c'est un problème de leadership en
europe que le président de la république
n'assume pas ou assume mal françois
hollande aurait dû taper du poing sur la
table
écoutez il est toujours jeudi les faits
en soit hollande il est désolé il est
toujours dans la valade dans le
compromis dans dans la petite manage
jury aussi dans la petite manoeuvre
intérieur c'est à dire vous essayez
d'utiliser situation européenne quand
même très grave pour essayer dans le si
la vérité le procès politique en france
du procès des deux procès totalement
injuste et attendez quand même la fin de
l'histoire monsieur retailleau
parce que aujourd'hui autour de la table
qui est-ce qui défend le compromis quel
est le pays qui défend le compromis
quel est le pays qui défend compromis il
y en a qu'un françois leur a tellement
jour dans le concept art nature
par nature je vous dis là est en cure et
l'avenir alors on taille au on ne peut
pas jouer il ay le volant situation au
children's c'est la situation de la
société et la situation ils se leurrent
quitte en cause cette oscillation
d'euros vous ne sait bien à ce qui se
passerait si je vous dis les compromis
hasard deux ans que cela pourrait
avancer car elle y compris pour notre
pays les compromis hasardeuses les
compromis qui ferait que nous remettions
au pot encore 15 ou 20 milliards
ce sera pour monsieur vous dire à la
sortie de la grèce non jeudi un
compromis un compromis fialon vous
comprenez si un compromis
s'il n'ya pas compromis fiable et bien à
ce moment derrière mais sinon et moi
c'est le contribuable français qui
paient à penser le prix bas je pense que
nicolas et bruno retailleau rêve parce
qu'il n'y aura pas de compromis fiable
puisque si prince revient après avoir
refusé un compromis auréolé puisque
auréolés du soutien de son peuple
donc le seul compromis possible c'est si
les européens cèdent par rapport aux
précédentes négociations sur une
restructuration de toute façon
indispensable de la dette mais en
revanche s'il ya cette restructuration
de la dette moi j'y suis favorable mais
à une condition c'est que l'agresseur de
l'euro car je veux bien donner la
restructuration de la dette à une
condition que la grèce ait les moyens de
s'en sortir après sinon on se retrouve
dans un an
en ayant gaspillé 50 milliards de plus
alors un écrin dernier a parlé de
l'armateur on parle de l'armée mais on
parle aussi de l'église orthodoxe la pop
a piqué la pop attitude on peut soulever
un petit peu ce qui se passe et on voit
aussi qu'il ya des coffres-forts geler
certains j'espère un certain nombre de
réformes
dupont aignan est ce qu'on pensait que
la grèce va pouvoir créer dans le calme
une nouvelle une nouvelle monnaie
françois fillon disait par exemple ce
matin qu'il craignait des violences
mais je vais vous dire les violences on
les a aujourd'hui s'il n'y avait pas eu
de sipera ce avec alliés d'ailleurs avec
un parti indépendant avec lequel je
travaille de cape annonce caminos il y
aurait eu des violences et si on échoue
à yaobou doré qui guette parti néo nazi
qui est dangereux euh je vais vous dire
le vrai inquiétude d euros des
européistes aujourd'hui c'est que la
sortie de l'euro marche c'est quand la
grèce va sortir de l'euro elle va mieux
marché et ensuite ça permettra de
montrer c'est ça qui inquiète les
européistes ca va montrer que la zone
euro est une
un instrument de division des peuples
car moi je remarque qu'on s'est
réconcilié avec l'allemagne qu'on a fait
l'europe qu'on a fait airbus qu'on a
fait des choses magnifiques en europe
quand tu n'y avait pas l'euro et depuis
qu'on à l'euro on a enfermé les pays
avec une même monnaie alors qu'ils ont
des structures compétitives différente
des démocrates fille différente des
cultures différentes et ça ne marche pas
alors il serait peut-être temps de
s'interroger sur ce que notamment
proposant pierre chevènement
c'est à dire le passage d'une monnaie
unique a une monnaie commune qui permet
des ajustements et la grèce est
tellement importante géopolymères
affirme eric dénécé pas théorique ya
neuf pays
attendez attendez il ya neuf pays mais
on n'en parle jamais de cela il n'existe
pas dalmat suède pologne angleterre ils
sont en dehors de l'euro ils ont de
meilleures performances économiques
personne ne s'interroge est ce que c'est
le chaos chez eux et je vous dis une
chose c'est que manuel valls a beaucoup
insisté il a eu raison
sur l'aspect géopolitique de la grèce
mais je vais vous dire les etats-unis la
russie et l'europe seront bien obligée
d'accompagner la soirée l'euro compte
tenu de l'importance géopolitique de ce
pays et on va mal
le contrat dans les prochaines semaines
de l'euro comment ça va se passer pour
la grèce crise aux cages toujours est il
que c'est vrai que le spectacle donné
par un la zone euro ces derniers mois
incapable de gérer quand même cette
crise grecque
ce spectacle est un petit peu désastreux
pour l'image de laurent willemez fa bow
et en même temps
on verra la sortie de cette crise est
peut-être qu'elle va d'ailleurs
renforcer l'europe il faut pas toujours
être critique vis-à-vis de l'europe
c'est une facilité que beaucoup d'hommes
politiques français s'offrent mais
l'europe à paris arrive quand même
l'europe arrive à surmonter dans la
difficulté un certain nombre de
difficultés l'europe est en train de
sortir de la crise c'est ça la réalité
la zone euro est en train de sortir de
la crise donc la situation de la grèce
nous sommes en train de sortir de la
grèce j'ai pas dit que tout va bien je
dis que nous sommes en train de sortir
de la grèce est passée de la france
pardon et pas seulement au delà de la
crise et pas seulement c'est vrai que la
grèce mais la grèce est une situation
très particulière
mais monsieur dupont-aignan si la grèce
sort de l'europe c'est pas du tout
l'europe de la zone de la zone euro
c'est pas du tout c'est pas du tout le
scénario rose que vous nous décrivez
ça sera un effondrement pour ce pays ça
veut dire que ça veut dire qu'ils seront
confrontés à une situation impossible
et là effectivement vous aurez vous avez
zappé c'est à dire et je construis en
ligne la zone euro serait catastrophique
d'abord pour les graisses menon si votre
crâne encore une fois d'ailleurs un peu
comme la france la france si elle a
perdu sa voix et son poids c'est parce
que un arbitre qui ne joue pas avec les
règles européennes
en remettant sans cesse à demain les
réformes qu'elle doit faire a une voix
beaucoup plus faible on le dira et bien
ce que je pense ce que je pense en tout
cas écouter on était les dernières
années dans le dans la case is home
vernet sommes sommes avec la croatie la
france est le seul pays qui a un déficit
de plus de 3% qui est vu son déficit
augmenter entre depuis 2004 que je veux
dire c'est que monsieur de free press a
ruiné les efforts de ses prédécesseurs
qui avaient obtenu des résultats donc le
monsieur qui brassent aussi a pris
l'europe ses bienfaiteurs ses
bienfaiteurs
il s'est désigné comme non non il a été
élu sur un probable démagogique très
bien aujourd'hui voilà il ya des
responsabilités s'il veut du
contribuable français
un certain nombre d' aide supplémentaire
il doit avoir je veux dire l'honneur
d'accepter une responsabilité l'europe
pour moi c'est une solidarité et
l'europe solidaire mais en même temps
responsable très bien m'écouter merci à
tous les trois venus débattre ce soir
sur le plateau du du 22h on termine ce
débat avec un dessin d'hergé ben oui on
a rempli on aura en prime un nouveau mot
en ce début d'été grec cite alors moi
j'ai cherché dans un dictionnaire
français ne pas trouver et lundi que sa
mère a le même temps d'essayer
merci à tous les trois on revient dans
quelques instants sur le plateau du 22h
sur la crise grecque avec le club des
éditorialistes ce soir sur notre plateau
lorrain laurent joffrin bruno jeudy et
jean louis gombeaud
mais tout de suite je vous propose de
faire le tour de l'actualité politique
aujourd'hui c'est avec caroline potier
nouvelle victoire pour jean marie le pen
le tribunal de grande instance de
nanterre a suspendu l'assemblée générale
extraordinaire du front national visant
à réformer ses statuts ainsi qu'à
supprimer la présidence d'honneur
jean-marie le pen se dit heureux de
cette décision sa fille marine le pen va
elle faire appel marisol touraine la
ministre de la santé a été entendu
aujourd'hui par les sénateurs à propos
du projet de loi sur la santé
l'objectif pour la ministre est avant
tout de moderniser le système actuel
tout en le rendant accessible à tous ce
projet de loi est donc le fruit d'un
long travail d'une forte concertation et
il poursuit un objectif celui de
permettre à notre système de santé de
répondre aux grands défis auxquels il
est confronté les conclusions du rapport
de la commission d' enquête sur le
fonctionnement du service public de
l'éducation nationale ont été dévoilées
elle prône la restauration des valeurs
républicaines dans les établissements
scolaires les sénateurs est avancé une
vingtaine de propositions l'on veut ré
astruit ray
inculquer des rituels pour faire en
sorte que en début de semaine chez
l'établissement et tous les élèves au
sein de sa cour d'école puisse parler de
ce qui s'est passé durant le week-end
pour faire en sorte de donner des règles
de fonctionnement
l'assemblée a approuvé l'actualisation
de la loi de programmation militaire
2015 2019
elle prévoit une hausse du budget des
armées de 3,8 milliards d'euros
cette rallonge à suffisante mais
significative permet tout de même
d'avoir à nouveau une certaine
visibilité et une certaine sincérité
finalement dans la démarche budgétaire
le texte sera soumis aux sénateurs le 15
juillet prochain
voilà et on revient sur la guerre la
crise grecque pardon ce feuilleton qui
nous occupe déjà depuis plusieurs
semaines avec le club d historia liste
ce soir nous ont rejoints sur le plateau
bruno jeudy bonsoir rédacteur en chef
politique à paris-match jour le gombo
notre chroniqueur économique bonsoir
jean louis et puis laurent joffrin
directeur de la publication marque de
libération par vous même ce soir à tous
les trois pardon pour ma voix qui petit
à petit en train de s'éteindre
on avait on avait débat politique juste
avant que vous n'arrivez sur le plateau
quel jugement vous vous portez sur
l'action de la france tout au long de
cette crise grecque
renault jeudi bonjour le feu bah écoutez
moi d'abord elle est très risqué
l'opposition de la france parce que ce
qui ce qui m'interroge moi c'est
françois hollande on l'a compris les le
dernier le dernier des finances de la
zone euro soutien
il existe six princes face tous les pays
du nord et même les pays dits du club
med ces fameux pays du sud qui sont tous
plus ou moins endettés d'accord on voit
bien une vision pour vraiment un gros
soutien les espagnols ont peur que
podemos gagne les élections à la fin de
l'année et les portugais ont fait l ai
pas envie de me trompe je la trouve
risque et je trouve logique parce que
françois hollande il a un atout dans sa
manche c'est que l'opinion française
pour l'instant est plutôt pour le
maintien de la grèce dans la zone dans
la zone euro même si c'est même si c'est
en train de bouger la scène mais quel
est le plan b qu'est ce qui se passe si
dimanche il n'y a pas d'accord pour
françois hollande est là je trouve que
si on fait de la politique intérieure
il ya vraiment un risque pour françois
hollande de se retrouver comme ça sans
rien dimanche soir un risque laurent
joffrin mais attendez si si ne dit rien
on va dire les absents qui est dit
quelque chose on va dire c'est risqué
quand même et s'il est trop proche de la
série c'est juste parce que c'est la
position russe
à mon avis si la grèce sort du système
c'est une défaite politique pour le
projet européen et donc il vaut mieux
éviter cette défaite politique il suffit
d'écouter les souverainistes
pour eux tout ce qui est mauvais pour
l'europe est bon et donc moi qui ne suis
pas souverainiste je considère que le il
faut essayer de trouver un accord
robuste accord n'est pas impossible à
trouver puisque apparemment les grecs si
tant est qu'ils arrivent à stabiliser
leur position ce n'est pas évident brrr
ils ne sont pas totalement hostile à se
rallier aux dernières propositions non
pas celle du jeudi qui ont été soumises
à référendum
mais celle du lendemain du vendredi
qu'ils apprennent à la pression sur le
parlement
mais surtout l'impression que c'est je
veux maintenant françois hollande qui a
l'air décrire la copie de d'alexis
prince et qui ensuite va essayer d'aller
négocier avec les allemands et et tous
les petits pays entre guillemets 2
de l'europe du nord qui eux voient d'un
très mauvais accord ces négociations
c'est une nouvelle négociation qui
s'engage avec avec une grèce qui a quand
même voté nous il faut le rappeler
dimanche à santa coulant qui avait été
proposée avant le référendum il ya les
bons et les méchants servent exactement
la copie de mes amis voilà c'est le
feuilleton d'été un bad cop et le kop
des rôles sont donnés tout de suite jean
louis gombeaud vous avez suivi avec nous
ce matin sur notre plateau on a diffusé
dans l'intégralité tout ce qui s'est
passé au parlement européen ce matin est
ce que vous avez senti les lignes bouger
non on n'a pas senti ni par contre j'ai
senti en écoutant les parlementaires
européens qui reflétait comme leurs
opinions publiques nationales qui avait
chez beaucoup une lassitude dans
l'opinion
on parle beaucoup de lassitude des chefs
d'état qui ça fait maintenant plus de
six mois
vous avez des gens qu d'ailleurs enzi
l'a dit hier et d'écouté moi j'ai
beaucoup de travail en italie à faire
des réformes appliquées et on me demande
de me donner mon opinion sur la tva sur
certaines îles grecques dont je ne sais
même pas où elle se trouve
il a dit ça donc effectivement il ya un
accaparement du temps du personnel
politique
et puis en écoutant les gens du piano
comme un sentiment on y monte un peu en
auront en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
ressentait anti grecs c'est excessif
parce que ça les calme apparent mais non
mais afghane ça c'est à dire que on est
il ya une lassitude qui gagne quoi ils
ont l'impression qu'on qu'on n'avance
pas du côté de ceux ci prace il reste
sur sa ligne malgré tout il dit vous
allez j'ai mes dettes et après on parle
des réformes et de claude ottan l'autre
on lui dit tu fais les réformes et après
on discutera éventuellement de la dette
et on est dans un dialogue de sourds est
ce le match lagarde qui dit ce soir
qu'elle juge nécessaire une
restructuration intégrale ça c'est une
avancée ont pas c'est disons c'est un
point de vue c'est à dire
qu'effectivement mais il ya aussi les
grecs qui ont envoyé un message quand
même au mécanisme européen de stabilité
cet après midi le nouveau ministre des
finances qui a dit qu'il demande un
allègement de 50 milliards
donc il reste sur cette position d'abord
et quelque part ça se comprend qu'est ce
que ça veut dire de demander à des gens
de rétablir leurs finances publiques
si au préalable ils n'ont pas un
échéancier dette à peu près précis c'est
c'est compliqué parce que dans un cas il
faut sortir 13 milliards si on ne fait
pas l'échéance et revoit pas
l'échéancier ça change quand même la
nature du budget qu'on leur demande un
élément c'est que sans être un expert il
me semble que si la grèce sort du
système
ça m'a coûté de l'argent aussi c'est à
dire que l'adepte elle veut pas être
remboursés beaucoup plus français
oui mais d'accord mais là les choses
étant ce qu'elles sont il faut choisir
entre deux solutions coûteuses donc
autant de prendre seul qui est plus
européenne que l'autre au pignon
politique en tout cas le spectacle donné
par la zone euro depuis des mois et des
mois
cette incapacité finalement à gérer la
crise grecque ça va laisser des traces
oui sage a dit forcément désastreux pour
la pour la zone euro puisque faire le
distinguo entre la zone euro et
l'ensemble de l'union européenne s'est
effectivement pas du tout un gage de
garantie de cours ça va pas générer de
la confiance au moment où il ya une
petite reprise qui s'annonce qui décolle
de manière inégale entre entre les pays
mais mais qui risque de ruiner le
semblant de confiance qui a notamment du
côté des pays du sud qui on le sait sont
beaucoup plus en difficulté par rapport
aux pays du nord qui sont guère lorsque
l'europe commençait vraiment à prendre
forme on parlait même de la zone euro il
est dit est ce que vous connaissez le
numéro de téléphone et est effective
on trouve dans cette crise là on sait
pas quel numéro de téléphone il y avait
un débat au parlement
mais ça peut être mais justement c'est
ça le problème c'est que ous ou par quel
canal passe les mécanismes de décision
entre leurs groupes le parlement
européen le conseil européen les
conseils des ministres
donc on en est là on montre à travers
une crise qui sur le plan économique et
financier je pense sauf pour les grecs
mais rien de dramatique pour le reste de
l'europe même si on doit payer que ça
mais ça montre bien que le mécanisme
décisionnel europe de d'europe les le
système institutionnel européen ne
fonctionne pas ça ne fonctionne pas
comment sait-il que depuis six mois
on discute du problème grec sans arriver
à le résoudre
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
quand même extrêmement le voit
d'ailleurs il ya une difficulté
simplement même qu'on ne peut pas comme
ça sortir la grèce de la zone euro s'est
même pas prévue par les textes de
laisser-aller l'unanimité je crois enfin
quelque chose comme ça donc on voit vous
même une décision aussi simple n'est pas
simple à prendre et que ce qui était dit
avant le référendum on voit bien qu au
lendemain du référendum
c'est pas plus clair il ya deux
conceptions l'europe soit c'est une
europe des règles de la rigueur
financière
l'allemande beaucoup de pays qui pensent
la même chose
soit c'est une europe plus solidaire qui
considère que si un pays est en
difficulté on s'efforce de l'aider même
si ça coûte de l'argent
et moi je suis plutôt favorable à la
deuxième solution et je constate
d'ailleurs que le la ligne dure et la
ligne de l'austérité ça n'a pas marché
donc en main en lui il faut être quand
même très très rigoureux austère la zone
euro est une zone de non croissance ou
de croissance très faible nous les coins
du pays ou si la situation s'est
améliorée quand même
attendez le portugal ils ont perdu 15%
de leur pnb
quand il regagne 1 % ont dit ce
formidable ça marche nous a pas d'âge et
dédicaces pour les compatriotes nos
compatriotes n'oubliez pas de prendre
votre liquide il faut de l'argent
liquide
est ce que vous êtes krief qui a
beaucoup d'hommes politiques commencent
à parler de violence du risque que la
grèce bascule dans le chaos si tout d'un
coup elle doit abandonner lors du sein
le grand risque c'est à grand risque
moi je pense le saut vue c'est que
écoutez franchement la grèce est quand
même au nord vous avez les balkans qui
reste très instable
la turquie qui est à côté la libye est
en phase 6 une grèce reste dans cet état
c'est à dire un état de non et a plus
une monnaie
les gens n'ont plus d'argent parce que
c'est qu'ils sont j'entendais à la radio
tout à l'heure une grecque et qui disait
nous sommes dans la zone euro mais on a
pas d'euro
cette façon très populaire de dire la
situation dans la dynamique que ça peut
créer parce que s'il ya une rupture le
les dirigeants grecs vont dire et ils
vont pas dire on a échoué on est nul
ils vont dire on a résisté et tant pis
on va rester tout seul le mieux se
battre
c'est une logique nationaliste et ses
dynamiques en tout cas une cohésion une
unité nationale oui mais c'est dangereux
aussi parce que ça le nationalisme
pensée ousamane ça ça mène à une
attitude plus ferme et plus au style
plus dur et c'est ça qui nous menacent
et ensuite cet exemple existants il ya
d'autres pays qui sont tentés de faire
la même chose
donc là il ya un risque de dissolution
finalement delà de la construction
européenne ce qui est intéressant aussi
pour évangéliser convoque les
conséquences sur notre classe politique
française ça réveille certaines
divisions certaines fractures qui date
du référendum de 2005 à l'intérieur même
par exemple des républicains les hommes
et femmes politiques sont divisés au
sein du parti socialiste également nonce
a ravivé effectivement la fracture de
2005 le nom la constitution projet de
constitution européenne
et on voit bien que les deux camps alors
à droite c'est un petit peu différent
parce que c'est vrai que le camp
souverainiste est un peu plus
marginalisés parce que les leaders de la
droite sont plutôt tout ce projet
européen des degrés divers mais c'est
quand même plutôt lent d'ivoire il voit
ressurgir le sont propres cauchemars à
celui de 2005 ebooks engagé pour le oui
c'est le non qui l'emporté on se
souvient de la campagne avec fabius qui
étaient contre effectivement aujourd'hui
se retrouvent à deux ans de la
présidentielle avec une gauche qui ou si
c'est une fracture qui est beaucoup plus
forte et qui a en ce moment il n'y a pas
la fracture n'apparaît pas parce que
tout le monde est d'accord pour essayer
la gauche globale et une réelle on a des
goûts manoir mélenchon une mélenchon
mais c'est vrai il se passe des choses
fondamentalement différent des 10 il
faut trouver un compromis donc une vis
tout seul on peut discuter du contenu il
faut le coup on verra dit je fais la
division version pro ni inclut des
mesures d'austérité ça veut dire que tu
y prends ça aura reculé et du coup la
gauche de la gauche va se retrouver
prise à revers
c'est pour ça que l'on joue une partie
sacrément risqué dans l'es10 si d'ici
dimanche et même d'ici le 14 juillet
j'ai quand même qu'aujourd'hui on a vu
resurgir ce qui est assez drôle c'est
que à l'intérieur de la droite et des
républicains on a vu ce chassé croisé
des positions intéressantes que juppé
qui la semaine dernière était plutôt sur
une position modérée qui a basculé au
début de semaine sur une sortie à
l'amiable
au fond c'est la position du ppe donc
celles au japon nicolas sarkozy lui et
rétropédale dans l'autre sens
la semaine est sur une position très ce
soir il faut trouver et ce soir il
partage le point de vue de françois
hollande sur le compromis ce qui est
plutôt assez marrant la journée
d'aujourd'hui c'est quand même par
rapport à je parle globalement c'est
quand même que on va plutôt à l'échec
dimanche
ces puits que l'ambiance sera peut-être
le contraire de bilhères en ossau mer
noire le site que d'un homme oui mais il
affirmé des choses mais il n'a pas le
pouvoir sur les choses la france votera
contre la sortie de l'euro ça veut rien
dire très sincèrement on vote on votera
pas que les grecs sortent ou pas d'euros
puisque comme lui a dit vous l'a dit
bruno ya rien dans les textes de cet exo
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
l'ambiance aujourd'hui au parlement
européen d'après ce que j'entendais et
comme on a l'impression que l'idée que
la grèce puisse sortir de cette
hypothèse se conforte se renforce
ça c'est en fait le contraire je ne fais
pas de pronostic mais l'idée l'ambiance
et que la sortie à la mer de l'euro les
12 pays sur la zone sur la zone euro le
kiki son tour il va falloir t'y prends
la décision de décréter cette sortie
monnaie et les banques grecques vont
rester fermés jusqu'à lundi
ce qui est annoncé aussi ce soir
toutefois ils vivent au jour le jour de
la bce la bce ne va pas faire ça pendant
plus d'une semaine encore c'est pas
possible
la wacc livre de vacances hervé beauvais
voilà donc pour les plages en grèce je
vous conseille d'acheter la grèce pour
les nuls vous aurez la grèce qui revient
sans surprise à la une des hebdomadaires
cette semaine on va faire une rapide
pardon revue de presse comme ensemble
par le point les charlatans contre
l'europe un combat historique ça c'est
la une du point
cette semaine l'express comment sauver
l'europe avec notamment une interview
dans l'express de cette semaine de
valéry giscard d'estaing le nouvel obs
jamais sans la grèce voilà pourquoi le
piège s'est refermé on change de sujet
avec la une de valeur actuelle de cette
semaine touche pas à mon église cet
appel à cette pétition lancée par de
limiter lead-in ac est les français qui
disent non à tout ceux qui veulent
transformer les églises en mosquée une
pétition qui a notamment été signée par
nicolas sarkozy qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
si les églises sont désaffectés ça me
choque pas qu'elles deviennent des
mosquées c'est le même vieux jeu parce
que je prenne fin je peux comprendre que
c'était même dieu non ça dépend portique
freinage a dit je sens un curieux moi je
vais vous dire parce que là où je suis
originaire du maine-et-loire énorme et
war il ya beaucoup d'églises qu'on est
en train de détruire parce qu'on peut
plus les entretenir
donc je sais je suis pas forcément pour
qu'on les transformer en mosquée mais
mais en même temps trouver une solution
aussi pour
les musulmans qui visiblement manque de
lieux de culte le matin cathodique
l'après-midi booster une polémique comme
ça pas forcément bon et puis on termine
avec la une du un maquereau un
philosophe en politique leur qui a
choisi sept semaines d'accorder un
entretien à ne laisser pas mal de pages
à emmanuel macron notamment sur sa
réflexion sur le rôle de l'état
mnm macoutes qui dit regretter le zydeco
idéologique des partis politiques
voilà bah vous êtes en train de
s'éteindre ça tombe bien on arrive au
terme de cette démission
merci à tous les trois d'être venu sur
ce plateau merci merci' hervé bonnes
vacances à vous aussi merci de nous
avoir accompagnés cette année tout au
long cours avec son trio merci j'ai très
bonne soirée à tous sur les chaînes
parlementaires